[Musique]
avec une entrée fracassante d'histoire
et conflits en 1981 lors de la première
guerre
des bombes et développer
et
des chars de saddam hussein
depuis les militaires américains
[Musique]
les français aussi
ceux qui s'en sert il
thierry prochain d'autres l'accusé
qui a peur bien c'est une brune de fonds
- c'est une arme formidable de verser un
premier morceau de saclay un deuxième
temps qu à partir du moment où un
certain nombre d'armes et dans le monde
développent ces nouvelles capacités de
blindage qui ne peuvent pas être perforé
autrement que par les hommes à uranium
appauvri
il est normal que pour garder sa
capacité opérationnelle de haut niveau
l'armée française envisage de doter les
chars leclerc de ce type de munition dit
robien je ne sais pas à quoi c'est parce
que vous savez déjà que j'accuse
je m'appelle jacques charme l'eau je
suis journaliste depuis 30 ans j'ai
couvert des conflits en afrique
lire entre liban
en irak et dans les balkans j'ai
travaillé washington une ville secrète
et puissant le 4 juillet 2012
je retrouve dans la capitale fédérale
américaine j'insiste dans la foule à la
parade de la fête de l'indépendance
mais j'ai l'esprit ailleurs elle rentre
d'un champ de bataille que les soldats
américains viennent de quitter l'irak
barack obama a mis fin à plus de 20 ans
quant à surpiqures des états unis rex
prix mais ce plus que j'ai vu est resté
gravé dans ma mémoire
[Musique]
vous
la piste de l'uranium appauvri
commençons niark
c'est un pays qui a traversé plus d'un
demi-siècle de révolution de dictature
de guerre et qui cherchent de toutes ses
forces à renaître
mais c'est un passé plus récent
est empoisonnée qui pèse sur le destin
des 30 millions d'irakiens
[Musique]
mon enquête débute à bassorah ce grand
port est coincé entre l'iran le koweït
et l'arabie saoudite en février 1991 il
est au coeur de l'offensive
internationale qui chassent saddam
hussein du koweit qu'ils avaient envahi
les blindés irakiens veulent fuir le
petit émirat
mais les avions américains maîtres du
ciel les attendent
je me rends sur les lieux de la débâcle
irakienne
j'ai fait la guerre du koweït contre les
côtes américaines
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter la
fuite du cored comment ça s'est passé
pour vous j'ai fait ça jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'au raid de l'armée irakienne
ce n'était pas vraiment un retraité pour
toi sur toutes les tables nous étions
sur la route les avions avaient bombardé
comme la route était dégagée et la
droite c'était très facile d'aborder
divers les chats je tiens cette route là
qu'ils veulent
l'ultime bataille de la guerre a duré 10
heures des centaines de chars et une
véhicule ont été déchiquetés abandonné
nantais ya plus tard un document
officiel américain explique pourquoi le
succès fut aussi foudroyant
route de la mort les pilotes américains
ont utilisé un nouveau venu dans leur
arsenal
ils ont tiré des milliers d'obus
déversant au moins 320 tonnes d'uranium
appauvri
ces obus sont équipés d'une flèche
pénétrante fabriqué en uranium appauvri
un métal qui percent to les blindages
il s'enflamme un impact atteignent plus
de 1000 degrés embrase leur cible en
dégageant un nuage de fines poussières
ce sont de véritables tueurs de chars
quatre pays ont su
les plus gros producteurs les etats-unis
la russie la chine et la france
l'homme naturel est un minerai exploité
dans de nombreux pays
enrichie devient hautement radioactifs
et est utilisé dans les armes atomiques
et des centrales nucléaires le résidu de
l'enrichissement étape d uranium
appauvri
il est faiblement radioactifs mais n'est
pas dégradables il doit être stocké ou
recyclés cinquante mille tonnes sont
produites chaque année dans le monde
à bassorah l'uranium appauvri est
accusée d'avoir laissé un terrible
héritage et je me rends à l'hôpital
central de la ville
[Musique]
je continue parce que dieu me prenne mon
âme a découvert un cancer du pancréas du
foie savez les pays qui ont déclenché
ces îles ont déversé leur poison fourni
et puis ils sont repartis tavana en
mille la première guerre du golfe mais
moi j'étais on est dû au théâtre nike
nike dans cet hôpital
je faisais des les avions en bombardier
sont venus nous attaquer
la suite si manichéen des concerts
enregistrés dans cette optique are in
death a commencé à augmenter fait
qu'empirer tout donner et hambourg aux
années 80 90 à in this will à deux
concerts ont été diffusées par catherine
chimiothérapie non non 1 600 1996
délégation est venue de sécurité un
responsable des services de sécurité
lacanau et il était au courant du
problème et dot
il m'a dit non d'un cv de eur12
objective de l'uranium appauvri et est
utilisé par les américains aux parents
imaginent murmurer à l'oreille que nous
avions ce programme des troubles
aussi alors mais l'augmentation des
quatre ans est non non vous savez ma vie
dont il signe au bout du compte les
points dès que quelqu'un se trouve une
grosse que c'est un cancer goretta 15
avant même que le docteur jawad al ahly
ne soit averti des dangers de l'uranium
appauvri
l'armée américaine avait produit en 1995
un film vidéo mettant en garde ses
propres soldats
entre les terrils de ce métal
[Musique]
ce film établit trois règles de sécurité
face à une source de contamination à
l'uranium appauvri s'en éloigner le plus
vite possible le plus loin possible et
éviter toute exposition de la peau trois
conseils impossible à respecter par les
habitants de bassorah je découvre un de
ces cimetières de chars présent partout
dans la ville des milliers de tonnes de
débris dont certains contaminés par des
poussières d'uranium appauvri sont
restés pendant 20 ans à portée de la
population et je vais demander à la
responsable du ministère de
l'environnement
pourquoi ces épaves n'ont pas été mises
à l'abri après 1991
nous avons été les listes complètes que
l'on découvre et on l'a marqué à l'est
de la couleur jaune
elle fait avant 2003 éducation non j'ai
refait au même endroit où l'est et les
pièces en question est ailleurs
même si on s'inquiétait déjà problème à
l'époque c'était tout relatif est bien
un toast à la situation est très
difficile la paix les autorités locales
avaient d'autres préoccupations sont pas
tous les américains depuis 2003 n'ont
pas envie
j'ai les noms absolument rien fait à
raison probablement à mon avis s'il n'y
avait pas encore mesurer les effets de
l'utilisation de cette arme n'est allé
voir les résultats
les effets dans 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans et
c'est dieu décidera de l'armement avec
lequel ils nous ont frappés y aura des
effets sur nos enfants et petits-enfants
12 arrière-petits-enfants
pendant les générations le mot jusqu'à
la fin des heures
le mal est fait restera mais personne ne
l'a encore mesuré une étude sanitaire
promise depuis des années par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
n'avait toujours pas commencé à l'été
[Musique]
pendant la guerre du koweït paris était
un allié fidèle des états unis et des
troupes françaises
ils ont joué un rôle crucial je contacte
la journaliste marie claude du bain qui
étaient en première ligne
les sharks avaient leurs biens calcinés
je dis est ce que je peux aller rentrer
dedans oui
ne paniquez pas miner non non tu pouvais
y aller il n'est pas miner j'ai soulevé
des poussières et des poussières
je n'imaginais pas que dans ce centre a
été mélangé des poussières d'uranium
appauvri mais de poche vous ferez vous
on voit pour moi c'était une maladie
auto immune dont on m'a dit qu'elle
attaquait
heller les muses de la thyroïde plus
certains problèmes n'auront community
sens à des délais des lésions vraiment
neuromusculaires pour mieux comprendre
ce qui est arrivé à marie-claude du bain
et aux malades de l'hôpital de bassorah
direction valence où je rencontre un
scientifique depuis des années roland
desbordes mettant en garde contre les
dangers de l'uranium appauvri
il est président de la criirad cet
uranium appauvri
on sait qu'il est pire au fond c'est à
dire qu'il s'enflamme spontanément à
l'air avec l'oxygène de l'air en venant
une combustion s'enflamme mais une
oxydation qui le transforme en oxyde
d'uranium
et cette fois une poussière extrêmement
fine est extrêmement fier et la cie va
être dans l'air et là on peut être
contaminé en inde air soit par
inhalation
si on n'a pas besoin soit par ingestion
parce que on va en avoir sur les doigts
l'uranium cumule tous les dangers
pourquoi parce que c'est un émetteur
alpha or les rayonnements alpha c'est
ceux qui font le plus de dégâts en
interne
2 parce que c'est un métal ou et que
l'on va le garder le métaboliser dans
l'organisme pendant des durées très
longues parce que pour qu'il perde la
moitié de son activité il faudrait
attendre 4,5 milliards dhs 4,5 milliards
d'années
c'est l'âge de la terre
cette inquiétude sur les effets nocifs
des poussières d'uranium appauvri est
partagée par des organismes sanitaires
français
toujours essayer le problème c'est en
cas de contamination interne
donc soit vous l'ingérer parce que vous
avez un environnement qui est contaminée
et vous en trouvez dans les eaux vous en
trouver dont on va dire la chaîne
alimentaire et vous ingérez soit vous
n'allez les particuliers agnant vont
arriver dans le poumon
là il ya finalement deux phases la
première c'est que ces particules
d'uranium doivent être dissous passer
dans le sang une fois qu'ils sont dans
le sens où à distribuer à différents
organes et puis dans ses différents
organes soient va s'accumuler sont à
passionner on cite souvent le cas des
gamins irakien qui vont jouer dans les
tanks qui ont été détruits qui récupère
de la ferraille qui si des ferrailles ou
des ménagères qui utilisent parfois les
méthodes de recyclage pour faire des
bassines dans lesquelles vont faire
cuire alors un péril
oui vous pouvez avoir potentiellement
des effets surtout qu'en plus si vous
avez une exposition répétée
même si elle n'est pas chronique parce
que ça va être le cas les enfants qui
viennent jouer
faire cuire l'eau dans la gamelle donc
avec une ingestion une administration
répéter dans l'organisme donc même si
vous avez des doses qui sont faibles
en tant que tel le fait d'accumuler ces
différentes doses peut éventuellement
avoir des effets sur la santé
clairement les poudres ou les poussières
d'uranium appauvri retombe se déposent
oui une fois que ça retombe évidemment
var contamination des sols sens c'est
clair après tout dépend comment c'est
contamination se fait est-ce que c'est
très local ou pas et puis est-ce que ça
va être dans un endroit ou si c'est en
vivre ou est ce que c'est par exemple
dans des choses qui vont être cultivé
donc donc c'est effectivement bien sûr
qu'il ya eu contamination de l'an
dernier pour moi les choses deviennent
plus claires et plus inquiétante
je suis dorénavant convaincu que les
particules d'uranium appauvri sont
dangereuses pour la santé et pour la
nature
la carrière des armes à l'uranium
appauvri a commencé en irak mais elle
s'est poursuivie au coeur de l'europe à
quelques heures
rendre capitale comme paris rome ou
berlin
[Musique]
je marche au milieu des tombes du
cimetière juif de sarajevo
c'est de là que les tireurs serbe tenait
sous leur feu la ville assiégée
les journalistes qui comme moi venait
ici couvrir le conflit se retrouver
derrière les murs jaunes de l'holiday
inn
en 1992 l'éclatement de la yougoslavie
précipite la bosnie dans la guerre d
avril les habitants de sarajevo sont
prises au piège de l'ue commencent une
mission impossible pour réconcilier
musulman serbe et croate
la guerre s'enlise et en 1995 l'otan la
dernière
ces avions essentiellement américains
bombardent les serbes qui sont
contraints de faire la paix
[Musique]
le tram au et de sniper alley nous
conduit a dit shi une banlieue aux
portes de sarajevo
[Musique]
je pénètre dans les ruines d'une usine
qui fut un des fleurons de l'industrie
militaire serbe
ici on répare et des tanks et des canons
les avions de l'otan ont attaqué cette
fois lusine dai ichi
en septembre 1995 et ont tiré plus de
4000 au but à l'uranium appauvri
avec l'instauration de la paix les
serbes daiichi sont allés vivre à brad
ou nach une ville de la république serbe
de bosnie dans l'est du pays y vivre
mais aussi mouiller nedelcu zelenovic et
journalistes c'est un témoin à charge
il a enquêté sur les bombardements de
l'otan son père son oncle ses cousins et
des dizaines d'amis travailler à l'usiné
mais cela m'est vraiment tous les
ouvriers qui travaillent à l'époque sur
jeanne d'âge
ik ce n'est qu'ils se sont retrouvés
piégés pendant les combats et plus de
recettes
moi je suis ravie procès date tous les
ouvriers sont morts et motos différentes
sortes de cancers entre 20 22 mille
habitants
sur ce nombre 5 % de notre population
originaire d habitude c'est en 1996 dans
le cimetière pour cent affichée en 2005
sont en terrain partout en france et 50%
qui sont origine jéricho dans six ans
l'un des renseignements
j'ai résumé andres izarra mastro douche
nu
[Musique]
il est mort de quoi notre fils on lui a
diagnostiqué par quoi cette leucémie
alors vrai salon répondu que c'était à
cause de l'uranium appauvri
mais établir la paix à grand renfort de
bombes a souvent des effets indésirables
je retourne à a dit shi à la recherche
des victimes oubliées
sami
[Musique]
mermet télé levitch et musulmans
pendant la guerre il a fui a dit shi
chassés par les serbes
en 1996 il rentre dans son village à
côté des ruines de l' usine d'armement
il retrouve sa maison soufflée par est
bon mais remet de la reconstruit sont
soupçonnés que la terre autour de lui a
été contaminé par les poussières
empoisonné
[Musique]
nous n'avons jamais été informés
personne ne nous a rien dit il doit même
pas le savoir même si cette maladie peut
toujours se subit ce combat on peut y
survivre au moins un des premiers je
connais ici au moins dix personnes âgées
de 35 à 40 ans qui ont un cancer mermaid
m'apprend qu'en 2004 il s'est découvert
un cancer du colon il a suivi une
chimiothérapie intense et il est en
rémission mais les nouvelles sont
mauvaises
ces derniers examens révèlent que sa
prostate et quatre fois plus grosse que
la normale et il a du sang dans les
urines
il a ça se fera je suis de rage il
je prends des douches normale et
maintenant j'ai besoin de naja très
chaud je dois porter des collants j'y
crois je suis argile par contre ces
postes on s'en est anémiée et je
descends immunitaire très longtemps car
et monitrices et tout ça vous êtes sûr
que c'est à cause de cette usine stopper
je suis sûr à 100% c'est ici à d'autres
maladies que le cancer
[Musique]
je suis la piste de l'uranium appauvri
en italie ce pays grand allié des états
unis au sein de l'otan a pris en charge
des missions humanitaires en bosnie puis
il a envoyé en 1999 au kosovo un fort
contingent s'interposer entre serbes et
albanais et c'est en italie que la
question de la nocivité des armes à
l'uranium appauvri va éclater au grand
jour
fin 1999 est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter comment c'est arrivé vite à
sarejevo l'indicé mais ces missions de
ces données sont sociales général et ses
malaises laissé quelques mots on était
heureux mais les concerne
le 13 décembre 1999
un mois après son apparition à la
télévision le sergent andré antonacci
est décédé
à rome je rencontre un militaire italien
qui a été lui aussi en mission dans les
balkans le colonel et mérico la tête
mais comme une seconde alors ça doit
sûrement s'attendre à 19 ans elle est
jeune je rentre en 1990 trafic et ils
veulent me souviens j'étais seul avec
les tahitiens personnes à l'hôpital de
thonon juillet tellement qu'est ce que
j'ai j'ai déjà dit qu'est ce que tu as
j'ai pas si notre occident bien ce noël
parce que tu ne sera sans doute pas là
l'année prochaine la bravo j'ai la voix
samassa lui mais j'avais cette masse de
24 cm de long et 14 de large et dont un
spécial une salle qui occupaient des
poumons examen ils ont un morceau de ses
dessins de seine a examiné de nombreuses
particules de ces rondes perfetta min et
john legend beaucoup de substance qui
n'existe pas dans la nature mais une
licence qu'un projectile à l'uranium
appauvri explose
ce produit est à l'âge de poussière
quiconque est une adresse de type civil
satoshi rodez et qu'elle mais moi je
ville dorénavant dans un corps me now
you be moment que l'on coop aux ménages
les morts se multiplient en italie
l'opinion publique c'est me et le
gouvernement doit réagir le 3 janvier
2001 le premier ministre de l'époque du
llano amato rompt le silence officiel
il annonce qu'il va demander des comptes
à l'otan
mais cette exigence de transparence va
avoir peu d'effet je rencontre le
général fabio min à florence il a pris
en 2002 le commandement de la mission de
l'otan au kosovo
immédiatement ils s'inquiètent des
risques présentés par l'uranium appauvri
à la suite des frappes de l'otan sur ce
territoire en 1999
lamy à katyn à dix commandements ont été
formés bruxelles s'en tenait un coût du
chantier de telle façon qu'ils ont des
rapports sont discutables problème aina
jobs sur le laissez pas les rapports
demandés mais notre et à des tous là je
suis pas très bon a dit m dias donc
qu'il nous était recommandé de se tenir
au film edit du fonds n'était pas un
artiste de militaires heine a traité les
munitions datant de paris comme cissé
n'a pas la même chose quelque chose que
l'on
[Musique]
j'ai encore un doute je rencontre en
coupe de france à rome les politiques
s'activent le parlement aussi pour la
première fois sans attendre une
confirmation scientifique définitive une
loi reconnaît le danger de l'uranium
appauvri
[Musique]
lorsqu arturo parisi devient ministre de
la défense en 2006 ce dossier est la
première de ces préoccupations allant
simplement passer en est notre
préoccupation là sauf les souffrances et
la douleur et d'allant délicieusement
les dommages n'est plus la ville ne soit
jamais supérieure ulm ce que d'une
certaine manière prévisions prévu le
problème de l'uranium appauvri et c'est
ça qui fut longue et non pas seulement
qu'elles produisent dans le domaine ce
que tout projet négatif mais c'est qu'il
promet c'est l'effet incontrôlable ou
qui vont au delà des temps présents
c'est ça le problème de l'uranium
appauvri quelque chose qui peut paraître
le goût de contraire de venir avec le
temps vais-je être
voici un obus à uranium appauvri sa
radioactivité de 40% inférieure à celle
que nous pouvons trouver dans cette
salle avec l'alliance atlantique a mis
du temps à reconnaître avoir utilisé des
armes à l'uranium appauvri dans les
balkans en 2009 un rapport officiel
évalue ce qui a été déversé à plus de 3
tonnes en bosnie
et 10 tonnes au kosovo mais le
commandement de l'otan se refuse à
établir un lien quelconque entre ses
frappes aériennes et les maladies des
soldats de retour des balkans lorsque
j'ai contacté le service de
communication de l'alliance à bruxelles
personne n'a souhaité répondre à mes
questions
[Musique]
en france alain acariès est un père
inconsolable
sophie c'est mort en 1997 d'un cancer
des glandes lymphatiques ludovic était
militaire et conduisait un camion en
bosnie un camion contaminées depuis la
guerre du golfe assure alain acariès par
des poussières d'uranium appauvri il a
fait confirmer ses soupçons par un
laboratoire indépendant
monsieur acariès leur a apporté quelques
échantillons du ganglion cancéreux de
son fils prélevés en france par
l'hôpital avant son décès un microscope
électronique d'une grande puissance et
une technique inédite mise au point par
le professeur gatti vont révéler
l'intérieur des tissus
on voit très bien regarder ce sont de
toutes petites particules des
nanoparticules elles ne sont ni
dégradable ni compatibles elles ne sont
pas compatibles avec la villa plus
surprenant encore la composition
chimique de ces nanoparticules
il ya de l'argent du chlore de l'or du
magnésium du silicium qui forment un
matériau très étrange qui n'existe pas
dans la nature
ça fait onze ans que vous travaillez sur
ce dossier vous avez poursuivi votre
action justice où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui bien on en est que malgré et
a révélé par le rapport d'expertisé est
bien le lien est niée avec leurs amis
ont appauvri mais pourquoi vous faites
tout ça moi je veux se veut qu'on
reconnaisse la vérité je veux qu'on
reconnaisse que mon fils a bien été
contaminés et par la botte de l'armée
qui n'a pas des contaminés caméo autour
du golf il faut il faut faire quelque
chose on ne peut pas laisser bâtir
statique fêté le plus grand dam de mon
fils était le plus grand cru public
une association avigolfe dont alain
carrier ses membres
a été créée pour alerter les victimes
potentielles de l'uranium appauvri en
majorité des militaires
et pour les aider à faire valoir leurs
droits devant la justice
j'ai rencontré la magistrate chargée des
dossiers déposés au tribunal de grande
instance de paris
mais la juge bertella geoffroy et bien
sûr tenu au secret de l'instruction
malgré la lenteur de la justice
alain carries qui a porté plainte contre
x garde espoir d'obtenir gain de cause
face à lui l'institution militaire reste
campé sur ses certitudes
nous ne méconnaissons pas les débats et
nous les prenons en compte
simplement nous observons que jusqu'à
présent aucune étude il le sait que des
études ont été menées ce soit par le
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement pas l'organisation
mondiale de la santé par l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
aucune étude n'a mis en relief n'a
démontré une quelconque conséquences
nocives à long terme pour la santé ou
pour l'environnement
il n'ya pas théâtre d'opérations sur
laquelle la france est intervenue
récemment dans lesquels on aurait
utilisé ses armes à l'uranium appauvri
dans ces armes ne titille utilisé par la
france sur aucun théâtre d'opérations je
vous rappelle que les armes à uranium
appauvri sont des armes conventionnelles
elles sont reconnues comme telles par
toutes les conventions internationales
ce ne sont pas des armes nucléaires et
ce à quoi le mot uranium aurait pu faire
songer
cette position de la france est en
contradiction avec les efforts entrepris
par le parlement européen
depuis des années les élus européens
demandent la suspension de la
fabrication et de l'usaj de ces arbres
ils ont voté en 2008 une motion dans ce
sens à la quasi unanimité
monica frassoni et la présidente des
verts européens
c'est vraiment un fil rouge qui commence
avec des étranges événements autour de
la guerre en irak continue elle se
renforce à la guerre en yougoslavie et
devient un des thèmes entre plusieurs
thèmes qui sont traditionnelles pour le
parlement européen
alors il y à un élément qui me semble
important et c'est que il ya deux pays
notamment la france le royaume uni qui
sont toujours refusé d'appuyer les les
bannissements dancla moratoire sur
l'uranium appauvri
très souvent on voit que il y a une
réticence énorme de la part des
gouvernements mais la part des armées de
la part même des forces politiques à
faire sortir publiquement un thème
l'urgence d'une plus forte intervention
politique face à l'uranium appauvri est
d'autant plus pressante qu'une nouvelle
guerre a fait apparaître un nouveau
péril
mes chers concitoyens en ce moment les
forces américaines et la coalition sont
dans les premières étapes de l'opération
militaire pour désarmer l'irak pour
libérer son en 2003 les états unis
attaquent l'iran george w.bush veut en
finir avec saddam hussein qui nargue l
amérique malgré douze ans de dures
sanctions
à l'époque je suis à bagdad j'assiste
aux assauts répétés des avions qui
criblent d'obus à l'uranium appauvri les
palais présidentiel
la guerre est rapide et ont trois
semaines les américains et l'imitateur
jim mcdermott est un membre atypique du
congrès américain c'est un des rares
parlementaires qui connaissent la guerre
de près comme officier il a fait le
vietnam et comme psychiatre il a soigné
les soldats qui en revenait une photo
qui dit que bush a menti je suis devenu
bagdad
je voulais pas faire de provocation et
j'étais sur place et a demandé ce que je
pensais de la situation mais nous allons
nous faut envoyer dans la guerre nous
avons simplement écrasé le pays
falloudja d'ulm et en sort we use m
nous avons frappé falloudja avec une
puissance énorme
[Musique]
en 2004 un an après le début de leur
formation
les américains doivent faire face à une
véritable insurrection comme bien on est
l'épicentre pour mater la révolte
la ville est écrasée sous les bombes
densité de feu des munitions au
phosphore et à l'uranium appauvri
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui la paix est revenue dans la
cité les mosquées et la vie a repris
sous l'oeil vigilant de l'armée
irakienne
avec sa patronne
le nouvel hôpital de fallouja le docteur
samir aa l'âme ne fait découvrir à
quelle voie d'affronter tous les jours
bon après match il ya trois nouveau-nés
à 1000 fois comme des plaies sont
prématurées de manière moins l'un d'eux
est né avec un vide-greniers
et quelle est leur palette 10 brebis ce
qu'on veut on faire du sport tout à
lausanne des sexes
oui ça puis 2006 constaté dans cet
hôpital une augmentation anormale des
malformations en jeu les snipers
hawass fait en accord avec tout ce qui
concerne l'écart enregistré par dix bacs
es ce normal de malformations effet ces
chaudes natexis ne devrait pas dépasser
1 à 2 pour mille oui examen de famille
avec 2500 wittock nous avons prélevé des
cheveux des parents et des laboratoires
indépendants
manille un débriefing et sa fonction
première de concentration importante
d'uranium dans les places
[Musique]
à bagdad le pouvoir doit dorénavant
tenir compte de l'avis des religions
leurs voix porte et leurs critiques sont
écoutés jawad al khali ci est l'héritier
d'une dynastie très influente
ils dénoncent ce qu'ils considèrent
comme une atteinte à l'intégrité
génétique de son peuple et des formes
ce sont les conséquences de
l'utilisation de lui racheter nos
projets nos choix qu'il a fait un effort
international pour une étoile aulas de
la même manière qu'ils ont réuni 30 pays
et leurs armes doivent prévenir pour
établir un projet de nettoyage lenco
marshall en allemagne car la situation
sanitaire on ira voir catastrophique
[Musique]
à
al'inverse de ceux qui l'avaient fait
après la guerre de 1991
le département de la défense américain
n'a jamais publié de chiffre sur la
quantité d'uranium appauvri l'utiliser
pendant la guerre de 2003 en irak les
estimations officieuses parle de plus de
2000 tonnes j'ai cherché depuis le début
de mon enquête
avoir une réaction du pentagone et après
des semaines des changes le mail un
porte parole me répond finale cher
monsieur
nous ne serons pas en mesure de répondre
favorablement à votre demande
d'entretien
le ministère de la défense et la
communauté scientifique enquêtent depuis
des décennies sur la sécurité
radiologique de l'uranium appauvri qui
est sur ses effets sur la santé et sur
l'environnement
le centre de contrôle et de prévention
sanitaire a conclu qu'il n'a pas
d'indication de cancer ou de câbles ceni
dans la population concernée à
washington thomas spectre est considéré
comme un sage de la diplomatie
américaine
il a été l'un des artisans de la
mobilisation internationale contre
saddam hussein en 1991 mais il s'est
opposé ouvertement à la guerre de 2003
airaq isuzu irakien qui dit escrime
sommes venus chez nous avons évoqué le
chaos qu'il ya 75 solution vraiment de
la vie sont en droit de les lever 3 et
je laisse aux sages de soccer chauveau
juge le soutien pense que nous leur
devant quelque chose si j'étais à qui je
pense que je dirais oui
[Musique]
et point de vue de l'équipement
militaire
du point de vue de détruire n'importe
quoi élite et ne veulent pas admettre
conséquences et la convention de genève
part de notre jeunesse dans ses veines
je ne laisserai les militaires la
réticence officielle à se pencher sur
l'impact sanitaire et environnemental de
l'uranium appauvri s'explique aussi par
des raisons économiques
évidemment du point de vue des armées et
les points de vue technique c'est doit
faire un trou dans un char nous rendrons
map aubry c'est génial parce qu'il est
vraiment efficace et en plus serrés
cycle donc voilà je pense que là il n'y
a pas vraiment beaucoup de petits
détails ce qu'un serbie ils ont pu voir
que pour nettoyer une tête des 30
millimètres qui ont été lancés ou pour
nettoyer là où sont tombés ils ont
dépensé 300 mille dollars plus ou mois
et donc ça veut dire que si je dois même
2.2 c'est peut-être win win situation
en même temps c'est moi je dois aller
nettoyer après c'est une situation très
coûteux exactement pour les pouvoirs
publics donc et ça c'est des chiffres
qui ont été qui ont été répandues est
cité
le coût de nettoyage en zone contaminée
rend difficilement envisageable que les
chambres la taille tu soit réhabilité
cette perspective est admise par les
états qui met en oeuvre un arsenal
de fait ils ont depuis longtemps accepté
que sur leur propre territoire des zones
où sont déposées stocks d'uranium à
grenoble reste pour toujours
inhospitalière c'est le cas aux états
unis qui ont accumulé sept cent mille
tonnes d'uranium appauvri sur une
vingtaine de sites à travers le pays
robert alvarez un ancien du département
d'énergie américain a depuis des années
dénoncé ce qu'il considère comme un
dangereux escamotage notre problème
certaine manière la chaux sacs c'est ce
que j'appelle les zones nationales
sacristie ainsi pour pouvoir amasser des
armes y avons dû créer de linge nous
avons les moyens tout risque bien de le
jeu de façon limitée de chansons avoir
lieu dans l'église ont été sacrifiés au
nom de la dissuasion et 90
cette façon fortuite que je fais en irak
une découverte étonnante qui confirment
les prédictions alarmistes de robert
alvarez
près de l'aéroport de bassorah des
carcasses de chars détruits en 2003 sont
alignés le long d'une route
les soldats me révèle un épisode
jusqu'ici tenues secrètes
richard hétu contaminés par l'uranium
unis kingdom discours de l'environnement
a testé ses chats exemple aux stations
de temps à autre les américains et les
britanniques
on est ici en entend porter des chars
pour les transporter les éloigner de
l'aéroport mais on ne sait pas ce qu'il
devait
mais moi je veux le savoir
en effet réexaminer cet endroit
mystérieux et la fin du voyage et le
découvrir ce serait la fin de mon
enquête je vais interroger le général
kabar comment de la police des
frontières dans la région de la soirée
partie de cette ferraille a été déplacée
vers cet endroit dans les airs comment
l'appeler vous quand est ce que ces
ferrailles ont été reclassés programme
est établi en 2000 allez sur ce site
provisoire l'énergie mais qu'il 150
tonnes et aux personnes what happened to
de s'abonner gates
que se passe-t-il avec un ferry terre
elle arrive la peine dépô t des neuf ans
au fond du trou
enfin les médias c'est tout simplement
on transfère de l'ain évidemment tabassé
dans des bassines et d'après nos
informations il ya des nappes
phréatiques chauffer l'eau m je fais
tout pour me rendre à faire elle patine
j'ai besoin d'une autorisation et d'une
escorte le général jabbar a promis de
m'aider mais un contre-ordre arrive de
bagdad
l' affaire dépasse son autorité et seul
un ministre peut me donner le feu vert
je connais trop bien l'irak pour savoir
qu'il n'arrivera jamais
one of une des premières choses qui vous
apprenez quand vous êtes gamin c'est de
ranger votre désordre dans les u15
attend d'eux qu'ils avaient de rabat
cvec a pu jouer nous avons choisi de
faire cette guerre et des rêves et nous
sommes responsables du chaos qui prévoit
demain si nous ne pouvons faire nous
allons dire c'est pas notre horizon que
la question de l'uranium appauvri
souffre comme toute question qui à voir
avec les armes et les armes les guerres
d'un problème de manque de contrôle
démocratique précis au niveau national
et au niveau au niveau européen et je
pense qu'il faut que la mêlée mot
d'ordre c'est de continuer la bataille
et au niveau des nations unies où c'est
très utile de le faire et au niveau de
l'union européenne pour faire en sorte
que on arrive un moratoire sur les armes
on m'a pourri
juste après les durs et les papilles
qu'il a envie d'être rappelé alors
utiliser et ne sont pas dangereux mais
nous verrons si la communauté
internationale ne reste pas inactive
face à ce genre de situation savoir 1
300 pour des voix là les dégâts dus à
faire entendre vous devez avoir des
preuves vous devez pouvoir dire que ce
sont plus que de simples hypothèses et
vous devez fournir des exemples du monde
mais au delà du simple usage d'une arme
à des dommages
il y aurait arrêté faire des provisions
spa sont bien supérieures chasse que
normalement il devait recommander un
produit apple
alors oui à ce moment là vous aurez une
bonne base pour aller de l'avant
les armes à l'uranium appauvri ont été
inventé dans les années 70 pour arrêter
en cas de conflit les divisions blindées
de moscou l'ennemi soviétique a disparu
mais cet arsenal à la puissance
démesurée est resté
et les responsables qui ont autorisé
l'utilisation devront un jour expliquer
pourquoi elles sont restés sourds aux
appels à la prudence
[Musique]
l'américain yahoo
ceux qui pensent ça y est allé voir
nicolas et non pas la plus petite idée
c
[Musique]